[MUSIC PLAYING]
JESSICA HARROP: Hi, I'm
Jessica and today I'm
going to be talking about
a chemical demonstration I
like to call elements on fire.
Let's watch as MIT's
Dr. John Dolhun--
here he is-- creates
a rainbow of colors
at the Cambridge
Science Festival.
JOHN DOLHUN: So
what I'd like to do
is do a grand finale
by actually burning
some elements since we're
talking about elements.
And we're going to have a little
rondo music to go with this.
So Clifton can go
ahead and do that.
I've got some lithium, some
boron, strontium, sodium,
and potassium.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
So there should be quite a
broad spectrum of colors here.
So the boron is a
nice green color.
The lithium is a beautiful red.
The sodium back
here is a yellow.
We've got a little
bit of strontium which
is kind of the bluish-red.
I think the blue is
probably the methanol.
And the potassium
is a little bit
of a violet in with
a yellow color.
Can you see those?
JESSICA HARROP:
So Dr. Dolhun puts
salts of five different
elements in watch glasses--
lithium, boron, strontium,
sodium, and potassium.
He also adds a little
methanol to each watch glass.
Then he lights them all
on fire, and they produce
flames of different colors.
Lithium is red.
Boron is green.
Strontium is a blue-red.
Sodium is yellow.
And potassium is violet
with yellow streaks.
So what's happening?
Well, the flame heats up
the elements giving them
more thermal energy.
This excites the electrons from
their ground or lower energy
state to an excited or
higher energy state.
This is what that looks like.
Since energy cannot be
created or destroyed,
any energy that was absorbed by
the atom must be emitted again
as the electron returns
to the ground state.
This energy is emitted as light.
So why do different elements
have different colored flames?
Because the difference in
energy between the ground
state and the excited state
is unique for each element.
And what does energy
have to do with it?
Well the human eye perceives
photons or light particles
of different energies
as different colors.
So red light is a lower
energy than yellow, which
is a lower energy than blue.
Think about it like
a rainbow spectrum.
So energy increases
along the spectrum.
Red is low energy light.
And violet is high energy light.
Going back to our
atoms' energy levels,
if the difference between the
ground state and the excited
state is smaller, the light
particle is of lower energy.
And we see that as redder light.
Conversely, if the
energy gap is larger,
the light particle
is of higher energy.
And we see that as bluer light.
And this is a simplified
picture of what's happening.
Each element has a unique
set of excited states, which
each leads to a different
pattern of light,
which we see as red,
green, yellow, et cetera.
[MUSIC PLAYING] Hope
you enjoyed the video,
and I'll see you next time.